a North Carolina appeals court says a
white man serving a life sentence for a
racially tinged killing deserves a new
trial
Chad Coakley was found guilty last year
murdering 20 year-old corn
Rodney Thomas Coakley yet shot and
killed the unarmed black man after 2016
after reporting hoodlums in his
neighborhood molla lankey reports the
appeals court decision came down to how
the prosecution raised the issue of race
in this trial nearly three years after
prosecutors charged Chad Coakley with
murdering Cora and Rodney Thomas North
Carolina's second highest court says the
trial needs to start over in the ruling
released Tuesday two of three justices
agreed the prosecutor in the case
improperly injected race into his
closing argument saying the argument
that Coakley shot Thomas because he was
black is not supported by any evidence
and his wholly gratuitous and
inflammatory Coakley called 9-1-1
shortly before the shooting in August of
2016 we got a bunch of who's out here
waiting I am awful loaded I'm going on
Coakley fired his shotgun from inside
his garage killing Thomas witnesses
testified Thomas was unarmed Coakley
claimed he feared for his family's
safety every day this man is with me
because he took my son Thomas's mother
says she has no doubt race was a major
factor despite the court's decision to
throw out the case I just thought that
it was over that you know my son can
finally rest in peace
I'll never have closure I would never
have closure lawyer Justin bamberg
represents Thomas's family the jury did
not convict Chad Coakley because a
prosecutor injected race into the case
they convicted Chad Coakley because of
how egregious his actions were an
attorney for Coakley agreed with the
court's decision calling it thoughtful
and well reasoned because one of the
three panel judges on the appeals court
dissented in the ruling the state can
he'll the decision guys prosecutors are
now reviewing whether to do that all
right thank you no it's not over yet
thank you very much mullah